Marvel shows on Disney Plus are set to
shake up the way superhero stories can
be told on screen he is why these series
might be different from previous Marvel
TV offerings and how all these exciting
series are going to blow you away
beginning with agents of shield in 2013
which centered around Clark Greg's
character from The Avengers there have
been a number of television shows that
have spun off of characters or events
from the movies making them officially
part of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
however even the Marvel shows to the
closest ties to the primary MCU such as
agent Carter which focused on Haley at
swells popular character from Captain
America the First Avenger still one
considered part of Marvel's phasers
Angie what are you doing here busting my
hump working a double what about you
shouldn't you be working English the MCU
has had three phases so far the first
began with Ironman and concluded with
the Avengers a second spans from Iron
Man 3 to ant-man and included 2015's
Avengers age of Ultron and a third began
with Captain America Civil War and
concluded with spider-man far from home
which served as a coda to the record
shuttering Avengers and the game however
faced fall include not only five new
films but also five new television shows
making this the first time ever that TV
shows will be considered an integral
part of the stories being told by the
film's Marvel's Disney Plus shows won't
be the first television series to
putting characters who were first seen
on the big screen Peggy Carter and Phil
Coulson and agent Carter and agents of
shield are the most obvious examples of
film characters making the leap to
television but Nick Fury Maria Hale lady
SIF and Howard Stark have also all
appeared in Marvel's TV series nobody
cares about the long game
damn am I doing wrong Jarvis but pulling
in a supporting film character for a
guest arc on a TV series as a far cry
from what Marvel will be doing but it's
an Arg your old crop of Disney Plus
shows which was sent on off on side
characters from the films but on actual
event just like Hawkeye Scarlet Witch
and the Winter Soldier recognizable
faces from the MCU ant an occasional
perk for the Disney Plus series instead
at there the main attraction by building
series around characters who have
already had significant arcs play out
over multiple films the first five
Disney Plus show to not only be able to
jump right into meaty storylines
skipping over introductions and origin
stories but they'll also be able to draw
the audience's existing attachment to
these characters instead of needing to
take time to build a perfection when
discussing that Disney Plus Marvel shows
Marvel Studios President and MCU
mastermind Kevin Feige told Screen Rant
we want to do something that's going to
stand right alongside the MCU films and
will be completely intertwined and the
story and the characters will go back
and forth between Disney Plus
programming and the film's this is
exciting for a number of reasons not
only can we look forward to storylines
that would jump between the series and
the film's making it a lot more
rewarding to be a fan of both but the
Disney Plus shows are already set to
introduce in popular Marvel Comics
characters who fans have long wanted to
see appear on the big screen DGM try not
to punch down the little skinny guy
why would I want to punch Fandral
hello tool three already announced the
Kate bishop who will appear alongside
Tim Barton and Hawkeye and Monica
Rambeau aka spectrum who will co-star in
one division then there are brand new
characters like Miss Marvel she-hulk and
Moon Knights who will each headline
their own series that's sure to be just
the tip of the iceberg when it comes to
Marvel's extensive roster of characters
and which ones they aim to bring to the
screen with their own Disney pleasures
in the past when Marvel shows have been
made they've been produced by Marvel
television and overseen by executive
producer Jeff Loeb who's headed up
Marvel's TV branches since 2010 some of
these shows such as Jessica Jones and
Legion for both popular among audiences
and well received by critics they've all
existed mostly independently from the
films which are all produced by Marvel
Studios and overseen by Kevin Feige with
two different captains at the helm of
their respective ships Marvel television
and Marvel Studios each charted their
own courses which occasionally vamper
aloud to one another but rarely
intersected new people were raining down
hell so go after the big green guy at
the flag waver I wasn't even there with
the arrival of the Disney Plus shows
however all that changes now Kevin Feige
is calling the shots for both the films
and the TV series the makeup phase forum
beyond this means that instead of an
independent movie verse and the mostly
unrelated TV world both the shows in
this series will be folded into a single
cohesive narrative for the first time if
the previous films are any indication
this means we can likely expect
characters from one show or film to
unexpectedly pop up in another
storylines two beginning one property
and finish in another one and four clues
to what's coming next in the MCU to be
sprinkled throughout everything with the
arrival of the Disney Plus Marvel shows
beginning in the fall of 2020 with the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier Kevin
Feige is promised new and continuing
stories which quote will be on the same
level of quality that you've come to
expect from Marvel Studios
further Feige has said that quotes these
will be major storylines set in the MCU
with ramifications that will be felt
both who the other Disney Plus series
were producing and their features on the
big screen from the way Feige is
speaking it sounds as though Marvel
Studios will be taking the exact same
approach to their Disney Plus shows as
they have with their MCU films weaving
them all around one overarching central
narrative however while Marvel films
have to get through their storylines and
little over two hours each the show's
will have six or more hours to which
to explore their stories that means that
the TV series could take the time to
delve into some of the longer or more
complex narratives that may have been
impossible to condense into a single
film like the relationship between one
that Maximoff and the vision for example
and can afford to finally devote a
significant amount of time to developing
characters who have previously had to
make the most of a handful of scenes but
across multiple films yep we're talking
about beasts oh I hate you
unlike previous Marvel TV series which
like most television shows have been
fairly episodic in nature Elizabeth
Olsen and Paul Bettany told MTV that one
division will be more like a six hour
movie than a conventional TV series or
actually if Bethany's description of the
script is anything to go off of may be
conventional isn't the right word for it
he further dished it's so Alan garden
weird and messed up and then you move
seamlessly in some more familiar
territory with a majority of the other
live-action Disney Plus series also
reported to come in at 6 to 8 episodes
per season and the TV series said to
directly impact the world of the film's
it seems safe to assume that one
division won't be the only show that
feels more like a movie if you're trying
to picture what a sig-sauer MCU story
might look like just think about all the
ground that gets covered between
Avengers infinity war and the Avengers
end game now imagine that instead of
these two three-hour movies the infinity
saga was one six hour show and marvel of
the possibilities nice to see you're
still as pleasant as you ever were
and it's just as nice to see that you're
still bulletproof Stark already the
showrunners for the Disney Plus series
are excited about the possibilities that
a new medium will allow them to explore
Jack Sheaffer the showrunner for one
division admitted we have these big
meaty questions that we get to spend
more than two and a half hours exploring
so that's been the work is making it
exciting and intriguing and head-turning
it's every moment
Captain Marvel producer Mary Livanos
seemed to agree with Shafer on the
expansive scope of the Disney Plus shows
telling comic book con that a television
format will allow Marvel's shows to tell
the equivalent of a full comic book
style event or multi issue story
typically in comics one story line
following a single central character or
group can play out over multiple issues
each one filled with twists surprises
and plenty of action and emotion it
sounds as though the Marvel team is
eager to bring this sort of focus
extended storytelling to the MCU
with a dis deep lush shows allowing them
to present satisfying character-driven
stories in their entirety
instead of parceled out one piece at a
time over the course of several movies
Marvel has already announced that it
will be using the Disney Plus television
format to bring some fun favorites into
the MCU fold however there are some
characters from Marvel Comics you may
actually fare better on TV than film say
for example teams such as the x-men and
the Fantastic Four who have previously
faltered under the two-hour time
constraint of a film but with the Disney
Plus series set to seamlessly transition
characters from film to TV and vice
versa the streaming platform may be the
perfect place for some of Marvel's most
iconic teams to make their debut before
jumping into the films it may also be
exactly the right venue to introduce
individual members of a group over
several different shows before teaming
up for a film or a Disney Plus series of
their own the first two phases of the
MCU consisted of six films each while a
third contained the whopping eleven
three of which were event films which
brought a wide group of characters
together from across multiple solo films
this has meant that Marvel has typically
been spending between eight to ten hours
on stories bridging the gaps between
event films introducing and developing
characters laying plot groundwork and
tightening the links between us multiple
ongoing stories previously it has taken
marble around three to four years to get
through these ten hours needed to set up
an event film due to the limitations of
only releasing two to three movies per
year but with the introduction of the
Disney Plus shows Marvel will now be
able to get through 30 or more hour
of story every year as opposed with
previous four to six such a massive
increase in how much storytelling marble
can fit into a single year may allow
them to lay the groundwork for bigger
stories even faster now instead of 10
years building up to the next endgame
level event we may get there and half
the time
although Marvel Studios has been
dabbling in a number of genres for quite
some time
Talton Captain America the Winter
Soldier is a political thriller ant-man
is a comedic heist film spider-man
homecoming as a John Hughes s high
school comedy and the upcoming Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness as
a horror film there are still some
genres Marvel has yet to explore
television opens up the realm of
possibilities not just to which
characters Marvel can introduce and
which stories they can tell but how they
can tell them for example one division
will purportedly be a sitcom genre which
only exists in television a teaser shown
at d23 seemed to indicate that the
series would take significant influence
from the Dick Van Dyke Show one of the
most classic examples of a sitcom format
and while we don't know yet how long
each episode of the Jeffrey Wright's
narrated what-if will be its animated
format and self-contained nature calls
to mind the animated shows of the 80s
and 90s including Marvel's own x-men the
animated series which had its characters
facing a different threats nearly every
week and largely resisted serialization
there's no telling what at the genres
Marvel will be able to explore through
their Disney Plus series even the ones
that have already been announced are not
genres anyone would have anticipated a
couple years ago but if the first three
phases of the MCU are any indication
we've only just begun to scratch the
surface check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about the Marvel Cinematic
Universe are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and at the Bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]